IT IS NOT CLEAR IF IT HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH HIS WORK ON
THE CAMPAIGN.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ATHENA JONES REPORTING FROM NEW
YORK.
LET'S DISCUSS WITH THE NEW YORK
MAYORAL CANDIDATE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ANDREW YANG.
HE'S ONE OF THE CANDIDATES YOU
JUST SAW IN ATHENA'S REPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
NEW YORK, AS YOU KNOW, IS FACING
THIS WAVE OF VIOLENT CRIME.
SHOOTINGS IN THE MONTH OF MAY
WERE UP MORE THAN 70% OVER LAST
YEAR.
WHY ARE YOU A BETTER CANDIDATE
TO KEEP NEW YORKERS SAFE THAN
ERIC ADAMS WHO ACTUALLY SPENT
HIS CAREER IN LAW ENFORCEMENT?
>> I'M SO HONORED TO HAVE BEEN
ENDORSED BY THE POLICE CAPTAIN'S
YUB ONHERE, THE NYPD.
THESE ARE THE OFFICERS THAT
WORKED WITH ERIC FOR YEARS, AND
THEY DECIDED I WAS A BETTER
CHOICE TO KEEP NEW YORKERS SAFE.
THEY WANT A PARTNER THAT THEY
CAN TRUST.
THAT THEY KNOW WILL FOLLOW
THROUGH.
WE DO NEED TO GET THE GUN
VIOLENCE DOWN, WHICH INVOLVES
ASSIGNING MORE DETECTIVES TO THE
GUN VIOLENCE SUPPRESSION
DIVISION AND BUILDING A NEW
ANTI-VIOLENCE AND COMMUNITY
SAFETY UNIT OF PLAIN CLOTHED
OFFICERS.
THE POLICE CAPTAINS AND
FIREFIGHTERS KNOW HOW TO KEEP
NEW YORK SAFE, AND I WILL BE
WORKING HAND IN HAND WITH THEM
AS MAYOR.
>> BY JOINING FORCES WITH
CATHERINE GARCIA, YOU'RE SENDING
A MESSAGE THAT VOTERS, QUOTE,
CAN'T TRUST A PERSON OF COLOR AS
MAYOR OF NEW YORK CITY.
I KNOW YOU ALREADY RESPONDED.
YOU POINTED OUT YOU'RE OF COURSE
ASIAN.
BUT WHAT DO YOU SAY SPECIFICALLY
TO THAT ALLEGATION?
>> I THINK NEW YORKERS RIGHT NOW
ARE LOOKING FOR LEADERS WHO WANT
TO WORK WITH EACH OTHER, WHO
WANT TO HELP PULL OUR CITY OUT
OF THIS CRISIS.
I THINK CAMPAIGNING WITH OTHER
CANDIDATES, YOU MAY NOT SEE EYE
TO EYE WITH THEM ON EVERYTHING,
BUT YOU KNOW THAT WE HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO COME TOGETHER TO TRY AND
GET NEW YORK CITY THROUGH THIS
CRISIS.
THAT'S WHAT NEW YORKERS TELL ME
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR ALL THE TIME
AND I THINK ERIC'S STATEMENT
SPEAKS FOR ITSELF.
>> IT IS NOT JUST YOUR
COMPETITORS.
MAYOR BILL de BLASIO CALLS YOU
AND GARCIA AN ODD COUPLE,
ACCUSING YOU OF OPPORTUNITYISM.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO HIM?
>> HE'S PROBABLY FRUSTRATED THAT
IT'S NOT HELPING HIS HAND CHOSEN
CANDIDATE.
>> THE RACE IS GETTING PRETTY
DIRTY, AND IT'S TOMORROW THAT IT
ENDS.
ACCUSATIONS OF RACIAL BIAS, NAME
CALLING.
ERIC ADAMS CALLED YOU A FRAUD.
ARE YOU WORRIED ALL OF THIS
VITREAL WILL LEAD LEADERS TO
SIMPLY SIT THIS HOME?
>> I TALK TO HUNDREDS OF VOTERS
EVERY DAY, WOLF.
AND THEY WANT TO TURN THE PAGE.
THEY KNOW POLITICS AS USUAL IS
NOT WORKING.
THAT'S ONE REASON WHY YOU ARE
SEEING THE EXCITEMENT RISE
MINUTE BY MINUTE AROUND MY
CAMPAIGN.
EARLIER TODAY WE ANNOUNCED WE
HAVE MORE INDIVIDUAL DONORS THAN
ANY CAMPAIGN IN THE HISTORY OF
NEW YORK CITY POLITICS.
WE WILL WIN THIS RACE TOMORROW
AND HELP BRING THE CITY TOGETHER
AND PUT TO BED THE POLITICS OF
THE PAST THAT'S TRYING TO DIVIDE
US ALONG THESE FALSE DIVISIONS
THAT REALLY DON'T SOLVE ANY
PROBLEMS.
>> VOTERS WILL RANK THEIR TOP
FIVE CANDIDATES.
IT'S A PRETTY COMPLICATED SYSTEM
THAT'S GOING TO BE IN EFFECT.
BUT YOU SAID TODAY THAT IF THERE
IS ANYONE THEY SHOULDN'T RANK
IT'S ERIC ADAMS.
ARE YOU ESSENTIALLY ENCOURAGING
YOUR SUPPORTERS TO GAME THE
SYSTEM?
>> OF COURSE NOT.
OF COURSE ERIC ADAMS IS THE
RIGHT CHOICE.
YOU KNOW, I THINK I'M THE RIGHT
CHOICE.
I WANT TO HELP BRING THE CITY
TOGETHER AND PUT IT ON A COURSE
FOR SUCCESS.
AND SO OF COURSE, YOU KNOW, I
HAVE MY OWN FEELINGS ABOUT
DIFFERENT CANDIDATES.
I'M CAMPAIGNING WITH CATHERINE
TODAY.
SOMEONE ASKED ME IF THERE WAS A
CANDIDATE I DID NOT HAVE ON MY
BALLOT.
I VOTED EARLY THIS WEEK.
AND ERIC WAS NOT ON MY BALLOT.
>> IT WILL TAKE A WHILE TO GET
THE RESULTS OF THIS ELECTION.
COULD BE WEEKS, RIGHT?
>> IT COULD BE WEEKS, BUT IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT NEW YORKERS GO
TO THE POLLS TOMORROW AND MAKE
THEIR VOICES HEARD.
THE MORE VOTES CAST, THE GREATER
THE CHANCE WE WILL BE ABLE TO
PUT THE CITY ON THE PATH FOR
SUCCESS WITH A MANDATE.
I VOTED EARLIER THIS WEEK.
RANKED CHOICE VOTING IS A LOT OF
FUN.
YOU GET TO CHOOSE YOUR TOP
CANDIDATE.
HOPEFULLY IT IS ME.
BUT THEN YOU CAN THINK ABOUT A
COUPLE OTHER CANDIDATES YOU
SUPPORT.
YOU COULD JUST VOTE FOR YOUR TOP
CHOICE AND MOVE ON FROM THERE.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
>> WELL, IT'S GREAT TO BE BACK
IN "THE SITUATION ROOM."
I'M GOING TO BE BACK AS MAYOR.
GO OUT THERE AND VOT